me now Florida Governor Ronda Sanchez
2024 presidential candidate coming off a
very strong debate with Governor Gavin
Nome last week Governor uh some are
calling this youu versus Haley for the
battle of the Trump alternative slot so
today in the hill we read that some
anti-trumpers in the Senate Mitt Romney
among them were backing her as well um
it seems like someone's trying to
establish an air of inevitability here
regarding Haley your
reaction well well I'm the true
conservative in the race I have the the
strongest record of actually delivering
results that's including the lot of them
and I'm somebody that would be able to
get in there serve two terms and
actually deliver all the things that
we've wanted to see delivered at the
national level just like I did in
Florida um I have more similarities on
policy with Donald Trump than I do on
Nikki Haley I think Nikki Haley really
represents uh the last gasp of a failed
establishment where she wants to force
everybody to register their identities
on social media she said I want their
names she said we should have unlimited
immigration that's controlled by
corporate CEOs rather than we the people
and of course she took the side of
Disney against me and the State of
Florida when it came to protecting kids
uh from uh sexualization of Elementary
School curriculum so she's at of step
with the vast vast majority of
Republican voters uh but I think some of
those elements are are people that
really want to take the party back back
to a failed establishment of yester Year
and that we know for sure that will not
happen Governor desandis we were just
talking about this devastating
Washington Post uh takedown of the
mismanagement of the war in Ukraine uh
it was it's a blockbuster piece um and
the Senate is now considering doubling
and tripling down along with the house
on what is has been declared by pretty
much both sides a stalemate what is your
view on this given the problems that
have already been caused and
encountered well we're functionally
bankrupt as a country we have massive
problems here at home you know they've
sent billions and billions of dollars to
do things like pay salaries for
Ukrainian bureaucrats pay for pensions
uh for for Ukrainian bureaucrats fund
small businesses doing things that that
American taxpayers should should not
have to do um and so I think that
Republicans need to tend into the issues
that we're dealing with um here in the
United States uh I do agree that uh
there is a there is a stalemate I think
if you keep funding massive amounts of
money two three years down the line I
don't think there's going to have been
much of a difference in terms of of How
This Ends so Biden should try to bring
this to a conclusion as president I will
definitely bring it to a conclusion now
Squad member um premila Paul is
getting a lot of heat governor for what
she said about rapes being committed and
documented by Hamas watch I already
answered your question Dana I I said
it's horrific and I think that rape is
horrific sexual assault is horrific I
think that it happens in war situations
however I think we have to be balanced
about bringing in the outrages against
Palestinians Governor your
reaction unbelievable uh you know they
what they did M did to to the Israelis
these are civilians many of them women
and children uh was barbaric it was a
new low of depravity I mean even Isis
didn't reach this low on some of the
things that Hamas was doing when Israel
was responding to defend itself they are
conducting themselves uh with standards
they are conducting themselves in
accordance with the law of War you hear
a lot of talk about civilians in Gaza
but just understand that is hamas's
Fault uh all the these civilians can be
protected if Hamas unconditionally
surrenders and releases all the hostages
uh they refuse to do it Israel cannot
sit there with a terrorist group on its
border that wants a second Holocaust
they have every right to defend
themselves and they should defend
themselves finally Governor um I know
you have some thoughts about Florida
State being left out of the college
football playoffs a lot of Heartache in
Florida you know I'm Obama fan I was at
the Georgia game um so I might we might
have a little disagreement here but
what's your reaction Trump apparently is
blaming you for this situation somehow
well uh yeah so uh they undefeated
conference champion and to be left out
in favor of two one lost teams and and
not those are good teams I mean don't
get me wrong the Florida state earned
that spot now people have said um you
know what's gonna is there anything you
can do they're actually looking to see
is there anything they can do I don't
know if there is any recourse but I have
set aside a million do in case there
ever is any litigation I'm not saying
that there's going to be they are
looking at it I don't think that this
has spoke well for college football and
we'll see and you know Donald Trump
wants to blame me you know he also said
that um he also took Disney side against
us when we stood up for the kids he also
said Cuomo in New York did covid uh
better than we did the attack me for
being pro- lifee maybe that's a reason
we should have a debate on your show
Laura stop being a keyboard Warrior and
let's uh step up and debate one-on-one
he's had a lot to say about me over the
last year say it to my face I'm game
yeah well you know the RNC has their
supposed rules they can't have debate
that all has to go away you need to go
head-to-head with Nikki Haley it will be
totally fair everyone will get a fair
shot and a fair chance to speak and I
know Governor um uh Haley would you know
quit herself well and I know you would
quit yourself very well so I hope she
takes our uh our offer on that and it's
an open invitation Governor thank you so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else